well the Congressional Black Caucus says
its mission is to quote we read the
website ensure that African Americans
and other marginalized communities in
the U.S have the opportunity to achieve
the American dream okay well that sounds
positive
but in fact the Congressional Black
Caucus is completely corrupt as everyone
who lives in Washington knows but worse
than that it's just a political action
committee designed to elect Democrats
they don't care about African Americans
and marginalized communities of course
and we know that
for many reasons but here's the latest
they are currently backing a white
Democrat over Jennifer Ruth green who's
running for congress in Indiana Jennifer
Ruth Green joins us tonight
Jennifer green thanks so much for coming
on now you would think you're
African-American the Congressional Black
Caucus would be
I guess on your side it's a race
specific group but why aren't they
backing you
thank you very much for having me Mr
Carlson the hypocrisy in this decision
is so incredibly clear we see that this
is about power and this is about policy
this is about process this is not about
progress these are the liberal Elites
who want to have power and are focused
on retaining it and so their decision to
back my opponent is hypocritical at best
because largely when you think about the
fact that I understand the black
cultural experience better than any
white man ever will I understand the
growth that needs to occur I understand
what needs to happen and I'm committed
as a black woman and as an
Asian-American woman to progressing
minorities in our country I seem like
the very clear choice but because they
want power over Politics the hypocrisy
continues to be loud and proud
well maybe you know how corrupt they are
maybe that's why they don't want to back
you
absolutely
yeah I mean I think
you know I'm sorry go ahead our district
as I'm sitting in our district we have a
third of our people in Gary Indiana who
are sub poverty level we have a third of
the people in Gary Indiana who live in
food deserts and so here are people who
are hurting and so the economy that
congressman Frank mirvan has voted for
has consistently put them in a place
where they have to choose between gas
and groceries where congressman Frank
Mervin has voted for three trillion
dollars in spending and has spent their
grandkids money and these are African
Americans who are clearly hurting and he
has zero regard for them and they are
focused on trying the CBC specifically
focus on trying to reflect continue to
elect him because overall they believe
he's doing a good job but I can just
tell you this Mr Carlson there is a a
line a mile and a half long of cars that
sit outside my headquarters
people who need to get to the food
pantry who need help and this is the
America that the Congressional Black
Caucus wants to act as if it is helping
black people and it is very clearly not
in Indiana's First Congressional
District I've been to Gary Indiana it's
one of the toughest places I've ever
been in my life and this or any other
country it's overwhelmingly
African-American
um it's really bad I would say what does
the Democratic party done for Gary
Indiana
ever you know what we have some amazing
people that live in Gary Gary Indiana I
have some amazing friends some people
that love God love others want to serve
both and I am proud to have Gary Indiana
in our district but when I think about
the reality of people that are hurting
because of these economic choices this
is a plan that has no action behind it
the congressman has no plan but if you
go to jrg.gop you will see a plan a plan
to help figure out the economic
processes that need to move forward and
I'm disappointed in the hypocrisy that
the con the Congressional Black Caucus
continues to provide because they don't
have a plan and they would rather
continue to crush people because it's
all about again their power and the
liberal Elites versus regular America
people who want to stay in power
although they are doing absolutely
nothing to make progress on the mission
that they continue to talk about well of
course if they care they'd be talking
about Gary Indiana and not Ukraine but
they don't care that's obvious
Jennifer's greens I appreciate your
coming on tonight good luck
thank you sir
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight